The guy goes, Hey, I'm bringing the bike in from Jersey.
Can you meet me at the Holland tunnel at eight,
the Holland tunnel come all into the city. He's like, Oh, I'm already,
you're lucky. I'm bringing it in. I don't want to find your, which I get.
I'm appreciative of the bring in. Okay. So I go, all right, well,
I'll have to sell her all night. That's not far. That's not far.
I could probably walk, but here's the clinker. I finally get my,
a calendar coming on. I got a seven o'clock an eight, 10,
and then like an, a, uh, an 11. So I'm like, ah. How am I going to do an eight,
10? If he's showing up at eight, the Holland tunnel.
So I do some mixing and matching. I get on at nine,
I do the seven o'clock run to the tunnel, get the bike,
hand him the big wad of cash. I got to lose that drunk all day.
Just had a couple grand in my back pocket. I give him the cash.
He shows me the bike and he goes, it's a great bike, great condition.
I'll show it to you. It's mint. He's at the 1980. Garelli it's an Italian.
MOPA this thing looks like a fun dragon baby. 1980. I went vintage.
Wow. The new ones are so cunty. So I wanted some, some zip. Okay.
So this guy is like a moped head. He's got all these,
he's got like a garage full he's. Like, this is my pride and joy.
I don't want to sell it, but I had a kid and I'm gay and all this I'm like,
all right. So I go, I'll just ride it back to the seller.
I'm at the Holland tunnel. I can't start it. What?
He told me why he thought I lied. I said I was a big moped guy.
Wait, what did he take back? Did he walk through the tunnel? He drove his truck.
Oh, it was on the truck. Oh yeah, yeah. Yeah.
I thought he was driving the moped pop, smoke and disappeared. Right, right.
I don't know if you can pull that, that hog to a tunnel. It's that'd be a risky.
I mean, they go about 60, but still all right. You don't get honked at all day,
but yeah. So now I got this bike and I'm on and like 20 minutes.
Cause he showed me, he did a walk around and he's like, this is a,
this is a clutch. The exhaust, the choke. I don't know any of this.
I'm panicking. I'm like, yeah. The choke up, choke you in bed, you know,
whatever. And he's like, all right, buddy, we've kind of made friends.
We exchanged hellos and goodbyes.
And now I'm on the side of the highway or whatever, West side highway area.
Just like trying to start kicking it. I'm twisting it. I'm turning it.
I'm juking. It I'm Googling. How do you start a moped?
I'm half drunk time cars are honking at me. It's like a horror movie.
It was bad. So I just walk it to the seller. It takes me forever.
Cause it's heavy as. I'm just w w you know, glug, glug along.
This is the saddest thing I've ever heard. So sad. I'm starting. I'm going,
what am I doing with my life? I'm faced to how, what am I 18? You know,
am I pushing a bike? I just paid a couple grand to a guy with an envelope.
He pulled up on a truck. He's from Jersey, had an earring.
The idea of walking a vehicle is so, so depressing.
And now I've got to bring it to the seller where everybody goes, what's that?
Start it up. Can I ride it? I'm not ready. I can't even start it myself.
So I got a lot on my plate here. That's not a bad move though.
You give someone pushing to right.
You're going to Dean Del Ray or some bike guy. He'd be like, take it for a spin.
That's true video. What he does. And then all of a sudden you got it.
That's not, but I, I kind of have a bucket moment,
like a block away from the seller where I go, all right, you loser,
you're getting this thing started. So I Google it or YouTube. It like, okay,
that's something. I pull that clutch. I pop it, starts it up.
I get on it. I go all over the shop. It was a revelation.
I felt like a new man.
Wow. I had like a.
What do you call it? A pithany.
So what I picture in, is it like a Vesper where you feed her on the thing?
It looks like a really skinny, shorter motorcycle. Okay. So it's like a,
it's closer to a dirt bike than a Vesper. Yeah. Yeah. It looks wise for sure.
But.
It's more of the power of a Vesper.
I guess. I don't know what a bullpen is. Motor pedal. What does that mean?
Maybe, maybe that's it.
Bicycle with pedals, mostly pedals. Ah, but you don't,
you don't pedal now, but you, there are there for your feet.
Okay. So it's like, do you kick it to start?
A kick is one of those things that's sexy. It's pretty cool.
Isaac would for this thing. Oh yeah. He's all over it. Big waft for that.
So I get it started and I go, all right, I've got about 15 minutes of my set.
I'm half in the bag. So my first ride on this thing, I'm house. Yeah.
You're breaking the law. Yeah. And I don't have a helmet, uh, whatever.
It's not registered. So I'm riding around the Hudson and Bleecker.
And I'm just like where the sun is in my face. I mean, the witness's in my face.
I'm having a great time. I'm like, this is the best thing I've ever done.
I went from, what the hell am I doing with my life? I suck.
I'm on the side of the road with a vehicle that doesn't work. I got ripped off.
I thought by this church, now I'm riding down the Hudson people going, Hey,
one guy goes great. Moped. I felt like Kramer. Oh, it was amazing.
That's a girl's bike.
So I pull that hog up to the VU. They let me park it inside, right? Yeah.
You know where the, the velvet rope thing is, how's.
The parking going to work and you put it on the sidewalk and.
I get, I'm nervous though. You could throw that thing in a truck. It's heavy,
but I have a lock for it, but still I'm nervous.
Yeah. You gotta get one of those big locks. I guess. I gotta, I gotta,
I gotta see this because I can't visualize.
You're going to have when you see it.
So I go, all right. I pull it right in there. Everybody's like, ah,
already Fuqua is like filming me. Like what? All this awesome.
He's a millionaire. That was fun. Bolt died.
He doesn't have one of these though. Nope. Not a 1980 Garelli so, uh,
I do my set, whatever, get off stage and I just go,
I couldn't wait to get back on it. And I just zip around with no phone really,
by the way. So no, one's bothered me and I've just cool wind in my hair,
learning the moped, feeling it, getting it. I know how to start it. Now.
It was a, it was a really a special day. Now. Where do you.
Park it at home? Is it just out there right now?
It's chained up to the,
I have a gate on the sidewalk is chained up to the gate and I got a cover over
it.
Well, this is a real, this is a trip down memory lane.
Well, you want to get on the lane? I had a wacky night last night.
I got to bring up, you know, the mopeds. It's a staple. Now my, in my life,
people are talking a lot of messages, a lot of tweets about it.
I did five sets last night and I go, Hey,
I'm bringing the hog out. This is the perfect night for the hog.
It's 75 degrees. I'll throw on a light jacket.
Are we calling it a hog? Now I'm calling it a hog. Did you name it?
The name of bike or is that just the boat? You name it? [inaudible] a boat.
You name a lady? I don't want to get on a lady and ride it.
Maybe bill.
A buildup it.
All right there. I'll call it bill until you come up with something better.
I like hug. Alright. We'll do hug hug. You know,
I grew up in hog Memorial drive. Ah, wow. A lot of fat chicks. All right.
So you're all really though.
Come on the hug bill and uh, you know,
it's per nicely and me and the lady go out and have a couple of beers. You know?
She's like I got out of work early. It's a beautiful day.
We go sit at [inaudible] on Greenwich jab and have a couple of pops in,
in the summertime. So I made up that true story. We go up there and then I go,
Oh, I gotta get to the stand. And she goes, well, I'm going to get some food.
I'm going to go to this place over here. And I go get on the hug.
I'll drive into the food and then I'll go to the stand. Wow.
So now I got the hog cooking.
I got the on the back. We go down to the food place and she's going,
I got to tell you this, this, this bill is, is hitting exactly my clips.
That's the thing with bikes. The women loved the bikes. I had no idea.
It was a myth. No, that's no myth. They come everywhere. Yeah. So sh.
She's holding me for dear anal and I'm going to blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
We're at the red light. And she's like, I'm getting off, like not off the bike,
I'm getting off this.
It feels exactly like my vibrator just smells like gasoline.
And uh, so I was like, wow, this is hot. So she's hugging me.
I can feel her legs clapping. You know, I was like, this is amazing.
I never thought I'd be this guy.
I never thought I'd have that moment in my life where I'm a blah, blah, blah.
And she's going, I'm so tired.
Wow. My life by, by kids,
myself in a room. So.
I drop her off and she's all hot and bothered.
I had to give her a couple of napkins.
I get back on the hug to go to the next set. But I got like a half hour 45, man.
I got plenty of time. Greg stone, Rachel Feinstein and Nancy DeVito there.
And they're having a good time there. They're cool.
And out and drinking and everything. And they go, let's see the bike. And I go,
all right. And I go, I gotta run though. So I try to start it. It won't start.
I go, this is embarrassing. They're going everything over.
Right. And it's so embarrassing. Cause there was like, it's a bike. Here we go.
We've heard about it. All right. And that's just all right. You know, nothing.
I looked like an idiot. Boy. I need others already.
The bike jokes. And uh, you know, anytime a comic does something outlandish,
you got to cut it.
Anything different. You wear a hat, people like what are you a hat guy?
Now you piece of. You are a hammer.
Loop on your gene. You're a mechanic. All the sudden. It's a whole thing.
They'll find it. Even if you're eating a hotdog, the hotdog is the focus.
You know, comics are so the bike won't start. And uh, I'm so embarrassed.
I feel like a kid again where like, I can't get it going. I can't get it up.
And so I go, well, let's get a drink. Let's get a drink. You know?
So I have to walk them back inside. And then when they get drink,
they start talking. I run back out and try to start it with. So.
It was so embarrassing. You're like Clark Griswold with the lights,
the Christmas lights, the lights.
Hanukkah.
So now I'm so embarrassed that I just pop the kickstand and just
walk it around the corner so I can start it in peace and not be embarrassed.
Right. And, uh, it's still nothing, nothing. I mean.
[Inaudible].
Oh, what am I doing? My life? I hate myself. Well, it is from the forties,
this thing, 1986. So I was like, what did I,
what am I doing wrong? I'm changing and with the choke up.
Turn on the reserve gas. I bled I'm tinkering. I'm like a man down there.
I take my jacket off. I roll the sleeves up. I have a cigarette. I'm tinkering.
I'm hating blacks. The whole thing.
I took the jacket off. Then you roll the sleeves up shirts leave. Huh?
I see. Yeah, it's hot out. So I go, it. The clock is ticking.
So I have to walk it to New York comedy club like.
Oh my God, blocks. Whatever is humiliating. Humiliated.
I'm in the street. Bikes are passing me cause I can't get it on the sidewalk.
It's too clunky. Oh my God. I suck.
So I park it and uh, I try to start it again in New York comedy club
kind of bucks, but it won't catch. And some guy walks by and goes,
that's outta gas.
Oh geez. The gas.
I forgot about gas. Oh my God. I guess I forgot gas existed.
I live in New York. I got a, I got a moped. I have a.
Gas situation myself. When I rent a car, I forgot about the gas.
Cause it feels you rented it. It's someone else's gas. It should be full.
So I guess when the guy gave it to me, it was low or whatever, you know?
Cause it goes 8,000 miles to the gallon. But so now I'm like, all right,
well let me Google gas station.
Yes. There's nothing. This is Manhattan. There's a yes.
And there's one on eighth Avenue.
All the way, Easter, all the way away.
So I go, I got three more sets. So I locked the bike up.
Everybody's making fun of me out of gas. You're an idiot, blah, blah. Yeah.
Do the set. I run to the seller, do the set.
I run to the VU, do a set. And then I go,
I guess I gotta go pick up the bike, but I don't want to pick it up.
I'm mad at the bike. I hate the bike.
So I'm sitting there with Jay and Shults and Sam and Phil handler.
It was such a good hang. Then Wolf shows up. Now we all start pounding them.
Wow. What a hat?
It was a killer hang was designed as a couple Epic as they say so now we're
putting them back. We're putting them back. These kids can booze, man.
You don't chase an animal and Wolf's the deviant. And we're having a great time.
Now I look at my watch it's.
Oh really? I still got to pick up the bike, get somebody else.
Snag that thing. If I leave it out there, somebody stole my bike, cover.
Jesus, can you believe it? What are you supposed to do about this?
I guess it's like nuts in a basketball hoop where it's just like,
that's the thing. You, you keep them as long as they're like, well,
we played basketball and a story of here moody McCarthy would.
Always bring a net cause somebody just take him. So you'd just put it up.
And we started just taking them down with us and put it in your pocket and
leave. But you can't do that with a bike cover,
but it seems like it's kind of like the basketball net.
It's just something that gets taken.
Yeah, I guess so. I mean fool me once I'm a cook fool me twice a month.
Huge for me three times about come goes like Nazi over here,
but I found a solution and I think I'm going to crack the code and beat the
crux.
So I've been Googling bike covers and I saw one
with a hole at the bottom that you can put the lock through.
So now the locks going through the hole, through the wheel and on to the post.
Now let me ask you this. Is there any damage to the bike?
Are they stealing the cover and then taking a on the hood or whatever?
This is the weird thing is I studied this and I mean, I got,
I could talk about this for an hour,
but I took a bunch of CBD I'm out of sleeping pills. So I was like, ah,
all I got CBD. So I guzzled it. And if you guzzle CBD,
you will get high. Cause there's like a, it's almost like non-alcoholic beer.
If you drink 90 of them you'll feel a buzz. Sure. Yeah.
So I was pretty high and I, when I get high, I'm paranoid,
the wife's out of town. So I was just laying in my, my apartment in the dark,
you know, with the covers up to my nose whimpering.
And I kept hearing this homeless person outside going
[inaudible] you know, and now you're even more paranoid. So I'm panicking.
I'm wetting the bed, the sheets of yellow. And I say, it.
You're you're 36 years old, go to bed. You're fine. You're just high.
You're paranoid. I go to bed, I wake up the cover's gone.
So I assume this hobo nagged it,
nabbed it and went and made a little bed out of it or a canopy or a mosquito
net.
Well, that would be almost the best case scenario if like a homeless,
crazy person. Got it. Because at least you were of service. You know,
maybe he made a tent out of it. He can live in it.
If it's just some whippersnappers stealing it, you know,
to wipe his with or some other dude who lost his. So he's taking yours.
That sucks. But if maybe if it's a kook, you can look at it, you know,
switch angles and say, Hey,
he needed it more than I did all that that no one brushes.
Right? Right. Well that then they asked if the bike is in disrepair,
the only thing I saw, and this is kooky and jarring and it makes your,
your Dick whole sweat.
There was a pile of cigarette Ash on the seat. Um,
what the hell is that? I don't like that. I don't like that either.
That means somebody goes, this guy.
So like in the eighties.
Did he burn a hole through the fabric?
No, whole it's a, it's a, like a pleather seat and it just had the pile on it,
but I wiped it and it was pretty, it was fine. So, so yeah,
so that that's a, a bummer. So I got the new one coming. It's got the lock hole.
So now when they try to rip it off,
they're gonna have to take the whole street sign, baby,
check on the hog gone.
What gone, the lock has gone. The, the, the, the,
the cover is gone. The stain on the cement, the oil leak is gone.
The whole thing's gone.
What is the, they clean the leak. That's nice.
I think that clean the link link soup. I think that,
I think I got towed.
Oh, tow. So this just happened like today or yesterday.
Yeah. I came outside today. I said,
I'm gonna go do some pull-ups on the scaffolding, like a. And, uh, the,
the bike was not a gun.
Is insane. I mean, where was it parked?
So it was parked somewhat illegally that you think it got towed or could it have
been stolen or what? Well, here.
Here's the clinker. The neighbors hate it.
I got a bunch of geezers and old bags living in this building.
And I think they hate it. The supers, like, you know, the neighbors,
they're all squawking about the hog and I'm like, God,
these cocoon loving guns. And uh,
yeah. So I think enough calls came in.
Here's why I think it was towed because it was too clean of a job.
I inspected, I got a magnifying glass. I went elementary Watson up your.
I got down on my hands and knees. I'm sniffing pebbles and do it, you know,
feeling the railroad track, like a native American. And it's too clean of a job.
I mean, if they cut the lock, there'd be some dust or metal shavings.
It's too good.
Boy. This is a bummer. That thing is,
has been nothing but trouble since the day you were born. I mean,
it's like the time machine, you got to destroy this thing because you know,
you got it to see where we've been, where we're going to figure out, you know,
humanity, but you know, you're traveling back in time to rape your mom. So,
you know, your dad doesn't die. I mean, this is getting strange.
It's, it's a Biff. It's up my. I'm wearing 3d glasses. Uh,
it's the power of love. I'm screwed here.
I've had a couple of nice moments on it. You know what if my bike is like,
it's like a retarded sun, you get a couple of moments.
He's eaten jelly. His hands are sticky. You know, he's cute. He can lift a car.
He's got a huge dog, but it's still sad. Every night I got to check on it.
I got to make sure it's still there.
I got to make sure the Puerto Rican kids aren't going to kill him.
Or he doesn't a toaster or whatever it is. But you got a couple of joy,
joyful moments, but the rest is misery and war.
Well, you got to do what you do with the retarded son. I mean, it's, you know,
it's no one wants to hear it, but you gotta, you gotta put some weights on it,
throw it in the river or sell it. I mean, sell it for parts and buy a,
a non retard vehicle.
But.
Also by the way, the thing is beautiful.
But I did see you riding it for the first time. That's a noisy son of a.
I mean, I can see why all the neighbors would hate. Yeah. You drove by,
I was walking down the street and I said,
if I was in an apartment that you were driving by,
I'd call up the and say, Hey, listen, we got a, we got a troublemaker out here.
That things louder than my, my, my sister's on a Wednesday night.
Hi, it's got a queen, like a, like a John Deere. I get ya. It's eighties.
It's from the eighties. Everything was louder in the eighties, you know,
share the other guy, Bano eighties, baby. Uh,
so yeah, it's old. It's a, two-stroke much like Louie, but, uh, yeah,
it's brutal. So, uh, I don't know what to do.
Maybe I'll put it in hock or whatever. Put it in the garage.
I'll I'll put it in the Smithsonian with the puffy shirt. I don't know. But, uh,
you're right. It's it's brought me a lot of hassle.
I mean, this is getting crazy. So what do you do?
You got to call the city or you call nine 11. You call your parents. What,
what happens? What's the next step?
The parents won't answer. So I'm just going to go down to the, uh, the DMA Anil,
and then let them put a big uncle, Sam, Dick up my. And,
uh, you know, I gotta pay for the shipping costs.
Then you got to get the thing out of there. And, uh, yeah, it's a whole thing.
I don't have to go. I'm sorry. I don't have to go to the DMV.
I have to go to the impound.
Right? So let me ask you this. What,
how do you take care of that vehicle? Legally? Like, if you were like,
I'm tired of this, what do I, what do you do with the vehicle?
What are you supposed to do? Put it in your apartment, put it on,
get a parking garage. Where,
where and how can you park this vehicle?
Cause it sounds like you can't park it anywhere.
I know it's weird.
I parked on the sidewalk every day of my life and it got towed.
Once you remember the big saga a year ago, because I didn't have a plate on it.
I didn't have it registered at him and insured. Okay, I'll give you that.
I get it. But now I got to play it on it. It's registered.
It's got a spit shine. I got, I got new tires on there. And uh,
I think this is just the call enough. And uh, you know, you get a lot changed,
you know, no more choke holds or by the police or whatever the hell.
So I think that's what happened.
So you think your hypothesis is the neighbors kept calling the police saying,
Hey, you got to get rid of this bike. It's killing us.
I think so. And they probably said, Hey, it's a hazard. I'm 900 years old.
I could trip on the kickstand and fall on my hip and uh, you know,
die in the shower. I've fallen. I can't get up. So I think that's what it is.
But I hope it's at the impound. That's the sad part of life.
It's the impound would be hell, just to get it out there as a whole thing,
you got to wait there with a bunch of construction workers going de Blasio.
I'll eat his out with a Spode, you know? And, uh,
so I hope it's at the inbound, but it's not it's stolen. The,
the hog is back and the neighbors hate it.
It was a neighbor who called the cops on the hog. They got a tote. I mean,
these neighbors are ruthless. They hate the hog. They hate fun. They hate me.
They hate comedy. They hate jokes. They hate bikes. It was up on the sidewalk.
I had it safe everyday, locked up. I can't do that anymore.
I'm scared a old man, Ronald is going to call the cops again.
So I have to park it like a, like a Schmo every day.
I got to go look at the Tuesday, 11 to four. Okay. And then I gotta move it.
Well, I say, these neighbors. They're rats. They're,
but Hey, you, dude. You got to park. I mean, what do you want?
What do you want me to do about it? You got a vehicle.
You've got a park that son of a. Well, my point is, and I hear you.
Loud and clear, but the thing is, it's fine on the sidewalk,
this bicycles on the sidewalk,
they just didn't like this on the sidewalk is the street I live on is historic.
And they got to have it look at nice. And that was an eyesore. And you know, uh,
this, this guy who was in the Korean war and he voted for Hoover Hayden,
like it looking bad on the streets. So that's it.
Well, he may be a stickler for rules. I love a rule. I'm a big rule guy.
I hate these people that hold the doors on the subway. I like you,
but I get it. If it were me, I wouldn't call in the cops.
Cause I'm not a, I'm not a. I'm not a rat, but I get it.
I get the thing of like, why does this guy get to do this?
Can I put my couch on the thing? That kind of thing. I hear you. I hear you.
Well.
Case in point, I don't even know what that means,
but a fellow two's gay said I got a garage in Queens.
Winter's coming up store the nuts, like the grasshopper,
put the hog in for the winter and live a carefree life.
So I'm taking him up on that. And thank you, sir, for the, for the garage.